and good evening welcome to fox news
prime time i'm maria bartiromo tonight
the states fight back coming up a look
at the nation's attorneys generals who
are pushing back on the radical biden
agenda
partly enabled by big tech now governors
and states ag's
are demanding answers florida's ron
desantis taking aim at critical race
theories
slow creep into our nation's schools we
will take that up later on with former
trump chief of staff mark meadows coming
up
but first the battles over biden's
border crisis
and big tech dominance playing out in
courtrooms across the country
texas a g ken paxton leading the charge
demanding answers from twitter
google and the biden administration
here's paxton with me on the program
earlier this week
we've asked twitter for basically
answers that if they're going to operate
in our state they have to answer their
state law and and despite that they've
taken this to
california you'd ask a california judge
about texas law it doesn't make any
sense to me but i guess
i understand why they want to be in
california because they don't want to
answer questions in texas which there
ultimately if they're going to operate
here
could have to answer those questions
and the questions do not stop there 21
ag's are banning together to save
american jobs
suing the biden administration over its
shutdown of the keystone pipeline
several other states are fighting the
administration in court over its
disastrous immigration policies
which have led to a full-blown crisis at
the border
one hundred thousand new migrants in
february alone
showing up up 28 from january
here's montana's ag on that lawsuit
this is devastating for states like
montana too and frankly it's put the
whole country in danger
violent crime in montana has risen by 48
just since 2013 now this is just going
to keep getting worse
under this moratorium order from
president biden and that's why we've
sued
and just yesterday the attorney general
of ohio filing a lawsuit over biden's
pork-filled
so-called coven stimulus package because
of the small print
mandate in the law that would block
states from cutting taxes for years
they are fighting back as democrats in
the majority in congress work to lock in
their power
and steamroll their agenda through
congress republicans try
as they might are largely powerless to
stop them
republican governors and attorney
generals are the last line of defense
against the ever
expanding power of the biden
administration it's big tech enablers
and the woke mob
cheering them on so who else is willing
to join this fight
joining me right now to talk more about
that is congressman jim jordan he is
calling for a hearing over big tech's
role in canceled culture as well as a
hearing on the administration's role in
creating a crisis
at our borders congressman it's good to
see you tonight thanks very much for
joining us
you bet good to be so i understand that
in the first
74 days of the new 117th congress
you've had no hearings in the judiciary
committee is that right and what have
you and your colleagues been doing
well they've been they've been taking
bills around the judiciary committee
straight to the floor almost every
piece of legislation that's passed in
the last three weeks we had jurisdiction
over but the full committee is yet to
have a hearing
we've said why not have a hearing about
this crisis on the border instead they
go around the committee
and they pass just 40 minutes ago maria
they pass a bill that gives
amnesty to three million illegal
immigrants so
amnesty while there's this chaos on the
border uh that
i mean this is so out of touch with
where the american people are but this
is how radical left the democrats are
and then of course the cancel culture
issue this idea that you know i always
ask it this way do you have a
functioning first amendment
when only one side is allowed to talk do
you have free speech when only the left
can define what can be said
so that's the situation we're in the
judiciary committee should be focused on
those two issues
instead they pass radical things like
defund the police federal uh federal
control of elections and now an amnesty
bill without having the kind of hearings
you're supposed to have on capitol hill
in the united states congress
so what's the response congressman
you're the ranking member
on the judiciary committee you've got
jurisdiction
over immigration law you manage the
floor debate
today for two democrat-backed amnesty
bills
you're not being heard well no we call
them out on the floor we have a robust
debate on the floor in fact this
the one in the one amnesty bill is so
bad it gives amnesty to three million
illegals and at the same time it has
taxpayer dollars
used to help illegals apply through this
grant program apply
for amnesty itself so i mean such a deal
for the taxpayer
i mean the disrespect that the democrats
in the house are showing for the
american taxpayer
with the the kind of legislation there
as there as the crisis is on the border
they're defunding the police they're
attacking american second amendment
liberties
they're federalizing election law and as
i said they're now giving amnesty to
three million
illegal immigrants who are here in the
country yeah there's also a blackout in
terms of the press
knowing anything about this as well
we're going to talk about that coming up
later in the show with kim strassel and
karl rove
where border agents are being told to
zip it
when it comes to any information about
that let's talk about big tech you have
made some demands
from amazon you want amazon to hand over
documents
related to conservative censorship
you've been you've been censored
well yeah i mean look uh what what big
tech did last fall what they're doing
all the time but what they did last fall
in the election i mean
the best example we had two amazing
witnesses last week in the hearing
in one of the subcommittees of judiciary
and and they talked about the collusion
between big tech
and certain players in big media where
they kept the hunter biden story
from we the people in the and everyone
knew that this the
the press knew about this big tech knew
about this but they kept it from the
american people
as we're getting ready for the biggest
election that we have the presidential
election so
uh what they're doing not only via
cancer culture but what they did
in the election to make sure americans
didn't get important information i think
is so troublesome so we're trying to
figure out
the best way to deal with this we think
section 230 has to be repealed
and reformed we also think you have to
look at the antitrust laws and the size
of some of these big tech companies
uh as as we move forward so do you think
you'll be able to be successful with
that you're in the minority we know
obviously that these big tech companies
are not
bulletin boards like they said they were
back in
1996 when they were giving this
protection for
their any liability they have actually
taken a side
you talked about the censorship of the
hunter biden story during a presidential
election period
can you do anything about any of this i
don't think democrats want to help us i
think they like the fact that that
that the canceled culture is is mostly
going after republicans and
conservatives now
but i do think the american people are
so fed up with what we've seen over the
last several
weeks and months whether it's you know
dr seuss mr potato head
what you know what what happened in the
world of sports where they've they went
after certain athletes for
things they've said and you know i also
think they understand that in the end
it'll come for them as well and i always
use the example
senator feinstein you know the san
francisco school board
even senator feinstein wasn't good
enough for the woke mob today
they said the dianne feinstein
elementary school will no longer be
named after the senator
because she said something 37 years ago
for goodness sake
that the mob doesn't like so i do think
that
there is this this up uproar from the
american people and at some point
we will be able to deal with this i we
could pass the 230 change right now
i just don't know if democrats are going
to are going to want to do that because
they think it benefits them
at this point all right this is
a lot of dangerous stuff we're talking
about as well as the health threat
with covet coming over the border we'll
keep following it congressman it's good
to talk with you tonight
thanks very much thank you